on va continuer là-dessus Paris que
menace de mort ins protection policière
les personnalités sont-elles en danger
vous allez voir le témoignage d'olive-
olive figure du mouement des gilets
jaunes qui va nous apporter des éléments
incroyables sur SK qu'il VI et Christine
Kelly journaliste bien sûr qu'on aime
sur C news et qui était avec nous aussi
souvent leurs point commun leur prise de
position certains chroniqueurs aussi
l'ont été hein vous avez été fortement
menacés regardez petit récap ils sont
avec nous vous allez voir des
témoignages de fou
regardez ces dernières semaines alors
que pèse un climat anxiogène en France
les personnalités S lettre de plus en
plus ciblé je trouve qu'on est les plus
mesurés excusez-moi et on reçoit
également des des menaces de mort de son
côté olive olive qui s'est fait
connaître du grand public pendant la
crise sanitaire et qui compte
aujourd'hui plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'abonnés sur les réseaux
sociaux où il n'hésite pas à prendre
position déclare aujourd'hui recevoir
régulièrement des menaces de mort qui le
cible lui et sa famille tu vas crever
sale fils de des menac à répétition
ciblé qui ont même contraint certaines
personnalités à être placé sous
protection policière comment on peut
aujourd'hui avoir deux personnes qui
vous encadrent parce que je suis
journaliste alors menace de mort insulte
protection policière les personnalités
sont-elles en
danger merci Christine Kelly ma chérie
d'amour merci d'être là merci merci
d'être là chir tous les amis bah oui
tous les amis tu as pas que des amis ici
olive olive merci d'être là citoyen
engagé et c'est la première fois que je
rencontre Morgan donc ton épouse merci
Morgan d'être avec nous olive OL
c'est un truc de fou ce qui t'arrive
raconte-nous ce qui t'arrive ouais ben
en fait ça commence il y a 2 ans où
c'est des groupes qui se sont créés sur
les réseaux sociaux où ils observent
toute notre vie he tous nos déplacements
nos faits et gestes jusqu'à
divulgueradresse de notre maison les
photos de notre maison quand on fait des
actions pour des associations ils
envoient des milliers de mails à ces
associations on a fait une opération il
y a encore juste avant Noël pour les
sinistrés du Nord Pas de Calais on a
amené 100 cadeau de Noël ils ont pourri
la mairie avec avec des commentaires
ignobles et puis là on a on est monté
d'un grade avec des menaces reçues à la
maison juste avant no voyer les trucs
c'est fou voilors c'est les les
premières menaces que tu as là où où on
me menace de pendre ma mère de
s'attaquer à mes enfants et à ma famille
et les dernières menaces qui sont
arrivées il y a 3 jours encore au
domicile euh où on va jusqu'à avoir des
photos de ma fille à la morgue c'est ça
ouais donc là ça c'est que tu m'envoyé
voilà on a on a tous les regardez tu vas
crever mais voilà ça vous trouver c'est
fou
ouais c'est ça ça s'intensifie de plus
en plus pourquoi ouais alors ça ça c'est
de pire en pire parce queon a
l'impression enfin ces gens-l ont
l'impression qu'ils seront jamais
condamnés on a déposé on est la 6e dépôt
de plainte et c'est toujours classé sans
suite donc moi aujourd'hui si je veux
parler publiquement c'est que quand
j'arrive à voir des photo de ma
fille excusez-moi mais c'est normal
ça c'est ce qu'on t'a envoyé quand
ouais incroyable quand j'arrive à voir
ce ce genre de photo je me demande en
fait c'est ça va aller jusqu'où en fait
tout ça et à quel moment la justice va
vraiment intervenir sur ces groupes qui
se développent en plus sur les réseaux
sociaux qui sont totalement visibles non
mais là là là c'est là c'est bien sûr
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est très grave
mais là toi tu reçois des trucs vraiment
c'est c'est c'est c'est directement visé
entre toi ta famille il savent où tu
habites ils savent tout le monde
aujourd'hui c'est toute ma famille qui
est visée c'est ma femme qui est visée
c'est mes parents qui sont visés c'est
on a l'impression que comme ils agissent
avec toute impunité ils se croivent tout
permis en fait on les voit d'ailleurs
irican il te reproche quoi il me
reproche mes prises de position alors on
a été voir un petit peu hein quel
étaient ces individus on retrouve désolé
de dire ça mais il y a beaucoup de
macronistes qui sont à l'intérieur il le
revendiquent eux même c'est pas moi qui
qui l'invente euh et puis des gens on va
pas se mentir il y a des gens aussi qui
étaient là au début du combat et euh il
y a une certaine jalousie une certaine
amartume de la visibilité sur les
réseaux sociaux il y a eu un peu de
plateau télé un peu de radio et
aujourd'hui c'est l'homme à abattre en
fait l'homme a abattre et comme on
arrive pas à le toucher et qu'il arrête
pas qu'il continue son combat parce que
je répète que mon combat moi je le fais
pour tous les citoyens pour un futur
meilleur et bien on attaque sa femme on
attaque sa maman on attaque sa fille
voilà on en est aujourd'hui alors
justement Morgane merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes la la compagne d'oliveolive
vous êtes marié je crois encore encore
fait la demande c'est ça voilà il a fait
la demande maisil fait pas comme
verdeand il s jamais marié Morgan je
sais que vous êtes très très touché
parce que vous avez été menacé vous
aussi ouis bah moi je vis plus je dors
plus j'ai peur chez moi j'ai peur chez
moi partout dès que j'entends un bruit
je suis en panique j'ai un enfant de 4
ans et demi à la
maison je vois la fille d'Olivier qui
est vraiment pas bien du tout elle est
en train de faire des études enfin elle
mérite pas ça personne mérite ça nous on
essaie de divertir des gens en tout cas
pour ma part sur les réseaux sociaux on
est tout le temps en train de les
défendre enfin on mérite pas ça moi je
suis je suis une mère de famille je suis
une femme j'ai envie de protéger nos
enfants et ce qu'on reçoit c'est
inadmissible on reçoit ça dans notre
boîte au l chez nous c'està direire que
ça commence par du cyber
harcèlement ça voilà c'est pas très
grave c'est grave mais mais aujourd'hui
c'est dans notre boîte aux lettres il a
une barrière c'est quoi la prochaine
étape il paraît qu'il y a quelqu'un il y
a quelqu'un qui vous s'est pointé à
votre travail c'est quoi ah oui oui oui
oui alors oui alors ça c'était il y a à
peu près un an euh la personne avait
traversé la France avait trouvé mon
numéro de téléphone et m'appelle un soir
vers 1h30 du matin en me disant je suis
en bas de chez toi j'ai un cadeau pour
toi h donc je me mets à la fenêtre je je
regarde donc la personne me dit qu'il a
une voiture de telle marque
effectivement la voiture était bien là
j'appelle tout de suite les gendarmes
qui sont venus qui ont déshossé la
voiture donc je regardais par ma fenêtre
j'étais très très inquiète je n'étais en
plus pas seul chez moi j'avais mon
enfant à la maison j'étais toute
seule ils ont désossé la voiture il y
avait aucun cadeau enfin je veux dire
qui roule comme ça euh une nuit entière
une demi-journée sans cadeau enfin
c'était quoi le concept là c'est qui
c'est quoi la prochaine étape on a enfin
la justice ne fait rien moi j'ai déposé
six plaintes classé sans suite classé
sans suite tu tu as donc tu tu vis que
avec ça ta famille vit vit avec ses
menaces constamment vous avez mais on
est tous inquiet chez nous on est on vit
plus ma mère vit plus ma famille vit
plus le père de mon fils est hyper
inquet enfin je veux dire c'est quoi la
prochain on attend quoi en fait pour
faire quelque chose on attend qu'il a un
mort est-ce que c'est à ce moment-là
qu'on va réagir mais c'est trop tard à
chaque fois les enquêteurs Cyril ils
font un super boulot et moi je tiens à
le souliner ce soir sur ce plateau euh
le problème c'est quand ils me le disent
eux mêmees quand ça remonte là-haut je
suis imaginez enfin quand même des
gendarme qui me dit je suis désolé olive
je comprends pas ça a été classé sans
suite moi je sais pas je je suis obligé
de me poser des questions au bout d'un
moment c'est quoi le problème
aujourd'hui de la justice c'est parce
que c'est oliveolive ou pas sincèrement
je suis obligé de le soulever ce soir je
comprends pas pourquoi les
investigations ils vont pas plus loin on
leur amène tout les captures d'écran les
photos les profils de ses comptes on
amène tout enfin il il y a plus il y a
plus cas et aujourd'hui bah ça monte ça
monte ça monte c'est des menaces alors
après c'est quoi c'est des gens qui vont
venir à notre domicile c'est des gens
qui vont venir à la sortie de l'école de
ma fille demain je vais demander une
mise en protection de ma fille enfin
c'est pas normal d'en arriver là ça va
en traumatiser ma gamine quoi mais
aujourd'hui enfin moi je vais pas mentir
je vais dire la vérité je suis un papa
et à mon avis il y a beaucoup de per de
famille qui qui réagirent comme moi dans
leur tête si la justice fait pas son
travail c'est qui va le faire est-ce
qu'il faut que je fasse les choses
est-ce qu'il faut que moi j'arrive à
trouver ces gens-là est-ce qu'il faut
que je fe je pose la question
aujourd'hui à la justice est-ce qu'il
faut que je fasse les choses avant qu'il
arrive un drame parce que n'importe quel
père de famille il va vouloir défendre
son enfant qu'on soit pas d'accord sur
mes prises de position c'est une chose
mais est ce qu'on soit dans est-ce qu'on
doit en prendre de dire qu'on va pendre
ma mère est-ce qu'on doit dire qu'on va
tuer ma fille est-ce que enfin est-ce
que c'est normal et légitime dans notre
pays on est en 2024 on va pas me faire
croire que dans notre pays on peut pas
réagir c'est c'est pas possible je peux
pas entendre ça et après la suite de
tout ça c'est bah des émissions qu'on
peut entendre chez toi Cyril on va
entendre des drames absolus des drames
parce que la justice ça aura pas réagi
parce que pour pouvoir envoyer ce genre
de photographie faut vraiment avoir un
problème psychologique et moi c'est ça
qui me fait peur parce que quand on peut
être aussi fou ils sont capables de quoi
ils sont capables de quoi ces gens-là
bah le souci le souci c'est qu'on a reçu
une première menace il y a quelques
semaines écrite euh c'est quoi la menace
quelques semaines la première écrite on
va crever
écrit dans la BO au l notre maison est
diffusée partout sur les réseaux sociaux
enin demain il y a un mec qui nous en
veut enfin il se pointe à la maison il
nous tire dessus on en parle plus hein
voilà on a donc dit sur les réseaux
sociaux exprès qu'on avait bien porté
plainte ce qui a été fait la personne a
renvoyé une deuxième menace avec les les
photos que vous venez de voir une
deuxième fois enfin le mec est tré c'est
un il est malade psychologiquement moi
j'ai plus peur d'un mec qui est
psychologiquement malade qu'un mec
musclé qui qui me déteste he tu tu ve
regrettez les prises de position d'olive
ou pas du tout vous dites il faut
continuer à faire ces vidéos à
s'exprimer dans les médias et cetera
alors ou est-ce qu'un moment vousz moi à
aucun moment je l'incite à arrêter ce
qu'il fait d'accord parce que dans la
rue les gens le remercient bien sûr
vraiment les gens les Français ont
besoin d'une personne comme Olivier
qu'on l'aime ou qu'on l'aime pas les
gens qui l'aiment pas ils ont qu'arrêté
de le regarder tout simplement donc non
moi je l'incite pas du tout à arrêter
mais par contre j'incite la justice à
faire son travail on va quand même pas
nous se condamner on va quand même pas
se p pénaliser et arrêter ce qu'on ce
qu'on aime faire et ce qu'on a envie de
faire pour des gens qui sont qui sont
malades psychologiquement non alors je
tiens à préciser quelque chose parce que
c'est super important parce qu'on peut
le voir on voit que c'est signé à la Alb
et dans la les dernières menaces qu'on a
encore reçu c'était c'était crré en
arabe mais avec une photocopie il y a
des éléments que je peux pas donner
puisque la gendarmerie m'a m'a demandé
de pas les donner il faut pas rentrer
dans les amalgames puisque aujourd'hui
il y a plusieurs indices en fait qui qui
pourrait laisser à croire que cette
personne voudrait faire passer tout ça
euh par une certaine communauté alors
que absolument pas donc moi je demande
c'est qu'on attende vraiment le résultat
de l'enquête et qu'on rentre pas dans
les amalgames ou quoi que ce soit enfin
il y a plusieurs indications sur les
courriers qu'on a reçu qui laisse
largement à penser à croire que je pense
qu'il ils aimeraient trop aussi que je
me mette demain à insulter cette
communauté alors que non j'essaierai de
garder cette droiture que j'essaie de
faire quand il y a un problème en
Palestine je condamne mais quand il y a
aussi des attentats terroristes je les
condamne aussi et je continuerai de
faire les choses dans ce sens-là Morgan
aujourd'hui olive olive m'a dit que vous
étiez vraiment très très très atteinte
que vous vous arriviez plus à VI moi le
deuxième courrier c'est moi qui l'ai
reçu pas le premier c'est Olivier
quielle a la boîte aux lettres on va le
mettre pour nos téléspectateurs voilà le
deuxième c'est moi qui l'ai reçu et je
peux vous dire que ma réaction a été bah
la réaction d'une personne humaine d'une
maman aussi avant tout et quand j'ai vu
cette photo de la fille d' Olivier enfin
oui je me suis mise à trembler j'ai eu
un étourdissement je me suis effondré
c'est mais ça m'a pris au corps
directement c'est c'est pas admissible
c'est pas concevable c'est ça ça tue moi
j'ai peur la nuit quand le quand quand
la nuit tombe je flippe quoi je regarde
je dors plus je me réveille la nuit en
sursau mais vous vous pouvez pas vous
imaginer ce que ce que ce que je
m'imagine vous dmez plus vous vivez plus
là mais je dors plus je vis plus je non
j'arrive plus j'ai peur voilà j'ai peur
et je veux que ça s'arrête et je vous
Remer merci de nous recevoir sur ce
plateau parce que j'espère et on essaie
tout et on fera tout ce qui tout ce
qu'on peut faire pour que ça bouge quoi
pour pour pour pas que cette plainte
soit classée sans suite et et qu'on
arrive à trouver l'ADN et puis les
empreintes de ces gens-là qui vont qui
ont peut-être fauté à l'envoi de ce
courrier je ne sais pas et je vous
remercie de nous recevoir sur ce plateau
vraiment normal non mais c'est normal
mais je tiens à le signaler quand même
Cyril parce que euh tu on le sait
maintenant j'ai quand même pas mal de
contacts et j'ai envoyé des messages à
tout le monde et le seul qui a répondu
présent encore une fois c'est toi et il
faut savoir le dire parce que c'est
facile de cracher toujours euh sur sur
les mêmes euh par rapport à des prises
de position mais je pense que quand on a
animateur télé aujourd'hui c'est pas
toujours facile non plus et à chaque
fois tu es quand même le seul à répondre
présent et moi j'ai pas de honte à le
dire parce que aujourd'hui cette parole
médiatique moi j'en ai besoin pour que
ça soit entendu au plus haut niveau
qu'est-ce qu'ils t'ont dit d'ailleurs là
les les policiers je crois qu'ils t'ont
dit quoi tu leuras dit que tu allais
médiatiser la FA alors exactement j'en
ai parlé aux gendarmes et ils m'ont dit
écoute olive euh enfin on voit que il y
a ces dépôts de plainte on voit que ça
grandit petit à petit et même eux ils se
sentent impuissant parce que je le
répète ils font leur taf et ils m'ont
dit je pense que tu as raison
aujourd'hui de passer à une étape
supérieure pour que ça puisse se savoir
parce que c'est pareil on le sait tous
sur les réseaux sociaux il y a tout et
n'importe quoi qui sont racontés après
derrière toi directement exactement et
aujourd'hui moi j'avais besoin j'avais
besoin que ça soit entendu
médiatiquement et je le redis moi je te
remercie franchement je te remercie es
très ému Oliv Oliv regarde aussi je sais
vousêes mais je suis inquiet surtout je
suis inquiet parce que tu vois tu as
posé cette question qui est vachement
pertinente quand quand tu demandes à
Morgan est-ce que je devrais ré tout ça
et je suis obligé de me poser cette
question parce que j'ai l'impression que
à travers mes prises de position le le
combat que je suis en train de mener
j'ai pas envie de bousiller de la vie de
ma fille non plus et quand tu as ta
fille en pleure au téléphone et qui te
dit papa tu as vu les gens quand enfin
comment ils sont et c'est pas les gens
c'est une certaine catégorie de personne
pour pouvoir en arriver là et ouais je
me pose des questions aujourd'hui mais
moi le combat que je mène c'est le
combat d'une vie en fait je sais que ça
peut être compliqué à comprendre pour
certaines personnes il y a encore un an
et demi j'étais sur ce plateau et je non
sait l'inflation grandissante qu'on
allait prendre en pleine gueule et on
est en plein dedans et je pense me pas
beaucoup me tromper sur certains sujets
que que que je peux exploiter peut-être
que des fois je me trompe sur d'autres
c'est à la rigueur mais est-ce qu'en
France on a encore le droit de
s'exprimer moi la vraie la vraie
question en fait elle est là est-ce
qu'on a encore le droit de parler en
France tu pense que c'est qui qu est-ce
qui t'en veut tu penses je pense qu'il y
a beaucoup de jalousie derrière tout ça
on va pas se mentir aujourd'hui on on
vit dans une société qui est très très
jalouse et si tu fais un peu trop de vue
si on voit un peu trop ta gueule sur les
réseau si tu fais un peu de télé et un
petit peu de radio derrière c'est encore
pire et ouais je crois que
malheureusement plus les gens sont en
souffrance plus ils deviennent méchant
plus les gens souffrent de leur
quotidien et plus ils deviennent
méchants sincèrement moi c'est ce que je
ressens et moi j'aimerais quand même que
tu que tu parles de ce jeune homme qui
t'a appelé ce ce jeune avec ce père
obsédé qui a des photos de partout chez
lui de nous truc de fou un truc de fou
j'ai un gamin qui m'appelle et qui me
dit écoute olive je suis obligé de venir
vers toi je vais te donner le numéro et
l'adresse de mon père puisque il nous
oblige à regarder tes lives dans le
salon il met le home cinéma à bloc il y
a des alarmes et il nous oblige à
regarder en fait ce que tu fais au
quotidien il a des alarmes sur son
téléphone dit que tu te déclenches en
live et il nous oblige à regarder ce que
tu fais enfin j'ai l'impression que j'ai
j'ai récupéré tous les tarets de la
terre non mais sincèrement ça ça me fait
peur non non ils sont chez moi euh
merci il y a Christine qui est avec nous
également Christine qui a reçu
énormément de menaces tu es tu as été
mis sous protection policière he
euh m oui oui j'ai attendu toujours sur
protection polici euh même si je le suis
plus je le dirais pas mais la protection
c'est un peu on a changé un petit peu de
style de protection mais pendant plus de
2 ans c'était une protection rapprochée
permanente et reç des vraies menaces que
tu peux nous raconter nos
téléspectateurs et ben en fait dès que
j'ai commencé l'émission Face à l'info
ne serait-ce que parce que j'ai fait
cette émission parce que certaines
personnes pour ne pas citer hxéon sur le
plateau ne plaisaiit pas un certain
public sans même connaître mes positions
parce que je rejoins ce que vous disiez
disz on on veut vous faire taire mais
euh parce que vous dites vous avez des
opinions mais même sans dire des
opinions sans donner son opinion
aujourd'hui on est menacer de mort donc
euh et et mais les menaces étaient très
sérieuses que vous avez été mis sous
protection policière qu'est-ce que vous
avez reçu comme menace les plus la plus
sérieuse qu'on va me décapiter ça
revenait systématiquement que si
j'allais tel ou tel endroit on allait me
décapiter qu'on voulait voir ma tête
tomber rou sur les rau vous avvez reçu
des menaces lettre à personnel l'êre au
travail l'ettre à la maison l'êre euh
par par sur le sur les réseaux sociaux
celui qui a été condamné euh
récemment finalement avec la l'enquête
de la police on s'est rendu compte que
c'était euh je pensais que c'était 6
mois de harcèlement sur les réseaux
sociaux c'était 2 ans et demi de
harcèlement sur les réseaux sociaux il
avait mon portable il m'appelait bon je
réponds jamais au numéro masqué mais il
appelait un peu voilà il a cherché à
avoir mon portable euhh il a payé pour
avoir mon numéro de portable et cetera
et euh et jusqu'à maintenant c'est
heureusement sur les réseaux sociaux il
y a un certain euh rituel qui s'est mis
en place où les gens dénoncent et très
vite euh euh les les postes sont
supprimés mais je comprends la terreur
que que vous pouvez vivre parce que
vivre en permanence en se demandant euh
qu'est-ce qui va se passer euh qu'est-ce
qui va se passer demain tu peur ah
j'avais peur je pense comme beaucoup de
chroniqueurs aussi ici euh où on se
regarde devant on regarde derrière on
sait pas ce qui va se passer on regarde
dans le parking et cetera et lorsque
j'ai eu la protection ça a été un ouf de
soulagement ça a été vraiment un ouf de
soulagement j'avais peur de la prendre
j'avais refusé à plusieurs reprises au
tout début des menaces de mort vous
m'aviez appelé j'ai pas oublié ça m'a
beaucoup réconforté je m' rappelle
Marline Chapa qui était au gouvernement
m'avait appelé et Emmanuel Macron
m'avait appelé aussi j'avais refusé à ce
TR personnes les plus importantes du
pays et j'avais j'avais refusé au tout
début la protection policière et puis
après lorsque je me suis fait aussi àper
sur une terrasse de café en plein 16e
arrondissement là on est on est passé
pass quoi c'était une femme qui était un
peu dingue qui qui voulait vraiment
s'éner v sur elle c'était dingue je suis
restée sur place un peu calmement mais
m'a insulté elle m'a fait beaucoup de de
doigt d'honneur elle est venue
m'insulter elle a fait le tour de mon
déjeuner la personne avec qui j'étais
plusieurs fois je pense que j'aurais été
avec une femme ou bien avec un enfant ça
aurait été pire j'étais avec un homme
heureusement c'était un ancien militaire
j'étais un peu tranquille mais je veux
dire c'està dire qu'on se dit on sait
pas à quel moment ça va vous tomber
dessus et après tu sors plus tu mets
plus le nez dehors tu vas juste ton
boulot et cetera donc avec la protection
policière ça m'a permis de sortir ça m'a
permis d'être un peu plus tranquille
mais c'est vrai en lorsque j'entends
leur témoignage j'ai beaucoup hésité à
porter plainte parce qu'on se dit qu'il
y a une efficacité peut-être au niveau
de la police et après une certaine
indifférence au niveau de la justice
heureusement dans ce cas-là la justice a
été jusqu'au bout mais c'est vrai que ce
n'est pas toujours le cas et c'est vrai
que ce que j' souvent dans ma position
c'est le fait qu'on veuille vous faire
taire il y a plus de liberté
d'expression il y a plus de liberté
d'expression en France comme vous dites
on peut regarder autre chose comme vous
dites on peut il y a 200 chaînes télé en
France 900 radio on peut regarder autre
chose on peut zapper on peut éteindre sa
télé mais non les gens veulent vous
faire taire veulent vous mettre à genou
et je pense qu'il faut que toute la
société toute la société se mobilise
pour qu'on puisse se battre pour notre
liberté d'expression pour c'est la
survie de la France notre liberté
d'expression et qu'on puisse oser faire
notre travail en toute liberté osez
vivre en toute liberté aujourd'hui les
criminels sont en liberté et ce sont
nous qui nous mettons en prison comment
pris avec une protection policière on
est en quelque sorte en prison et les
criminels sont en liberté et comme vous
le disiez aussi en phigran ça santait
derrière ils seront éventuellement
disculpés pour des problèmes PS un jour
un schizophrène est rentré chez moi ben
c'est il est il est fou et les policiers
m'ont dit mais écoutez il est fou
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise il est fou on l'a sermonné mais il
est fou alors à quel moment il va
revenir chez vous donc à quel moment
vous vous dites vous êtes tranquille et
que vous déménagez vous faites quoi donc
c'est une peur permanence et ça
s'appelle la terreur on parlera demain
des des menaces he sur les les
chroniqueurs vous allez voir c'est un
truc de fou merci olive olive merci
Christine Kell on vous retrouve sur C
news êtes formidable merci Morgane
également d'avoir été avec nous tout
suite c'est monongeville sur C8
merci